[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans la
matinale de rtl france et ses pairs à
paris bonjour bonjour magali bienvenue à
tous sans plus attendre les titres de
l'actualité de ce jeudi matin
le président brésilien sous la menace
d'une inculpation pour crime contre
l'humanité des sénateurs de tous bords
réclament sa mise en cause dans sa
gestion qu'ovide des accusations à
porter surtout symbolique puisque rahim
also know bénéficie de soutiens au
parlement quant à faire barrage à une
éventuelle destitution
le conseil de sécurité réuni en urgence
après un nouveau tir de missile
confirmée par la corée du nord c'est le
huitième lancement en mois de deux mois
un missile lancé cette fois depuis un
sous-marin il s'y rend cher à l'armement
de pyongyang pour peser sur une
éventuelle reprise de dialogue au point
mort avec washington depuis des mois
et puis là la prolongation du pass and i
ter en france à adopter de justesse à
l'assemblée la nuit dernière
l'opposition fustige site un chèque en
blanc dans un état d'exception
impasse sanitaire qui entre en vigueur
aujourd'hui au maroc on va le voir ou en
bulgarie est toujours contestée en
italie depuis son imposition à tous les
salariés le port de trieste est devenue
le symbole de la résistance
[Musique]
comment faire baisser le prix de
l'énergie pour les consommateurs réunis
en sommet aujourd'hui et demain à
bruxelles les 27 pays européens vont
tenter de trouver des solutions alors
qu'ils sont très divisés sur une
stratégie commune la présidente de la
commission a déjà averti cette crise de
l'énergie ne doit pas être une excuse
pour retarder la transition écologique
décryptage avec notre invité à 8 heures
et on commence donc par le brésil où les
sénateurs ont demandé l'inculpation de
ailleurs bolton arrow il accuse le
président de des crimes ou pas - dont
celui de crime contre l'humanité pour sa
gestion calamiteuse qu'elle a fui tous
de la crise du coc vide oui après six
mois d'auditions la commission d'
enquête parlementaire met aussi en cause
une soixantaine de personnes dans
l'entourage du président est des
accusations symbolique puisque jaillir
ball sudaro peut compter sur le soutien
de la majorité au parlement quand un mot
clair
10 c'est le nombre de crimes retenu par
des sénateurs brésiliens à l'encontre de
jaillir bol sonar où le président est
accusé de charlatanisme d'infraction aux
mesures sanitaires ou encore de
prévarication après l' enquête de six
mois menée par une commission
parlementaire sur la gestion de la crise
sanitaire les sénateurs ont demandé
l'inculpation de leur président
le gouvernement a choisi d'exposer la
population d'amazonas au virus afin
d'obtenir plus rapidement une immunité
naturelle une immunité collective une
immunité de troupeaux
les travaux de cette commission d'
enquête du sénat ont révélé que
l'acquisition de vaccins n'étaient pas
une priorité
pour la commission les conclusions de l
enquête sont claires et nettes gerben
sonar haut et le principal responsable
de la situation sanitaire actuelle au
brésil dans son rapport la cpi accusent
également le président brésilien de
crimes contre l'humanité ces accusations
pourront être jugé à la cour pénale
internationale de la haye rouge annonce
lidge âge que quelques arbres à
cames le génocide comme je l'expliqué
une fois le répète n'a pas été supprimée
il a été échangé contre des crimes
contre l'humanité il sera inculpé pour
crimes contre l'humanité en raison des
affaires sur près 26 niort manaus et les
indigènes ce qui a été supprimé c'est
l'homicide
à
domicile ou accusé d'avoir eu une
politique favorisant une contamination
de masse de sa population
jr ball somaro avait qualifié de grippe
est le co vite 19 afin de minimiser
l'épidémie une nouvelle fois attaqué sur
sa gestion de la crise sanitaire j'aille
à bolton araud a réagi ce mercredi
le président brésilien nie en bloc tous
les faits qui lui sont reprochés
[Applaudissements]
nous le savons que nous sommes coupables
d' absolument rien nous savons que nous
avons fait ce qu'il fallait dès le début
[Applaudissements]
comme ce serait bien si cette cpi avait
fait quelque chose de productif pour
notre pays
les accusations de la commission
sénatoriale devrait rester sans
conséquence au parlement le président
brésilien bénéficie d' assez d'alliés
pour lui éviter une procédure de
destitution
sur le plan judiciaire le procureur
général a augusto arras proche de
jaillir bolton arrow pourra s'opposer à
toute inculpation au total plus de 600
milles brésiliens sont décédées des
suites du coc vite 19 depuis le début de
la pandémie ce qui fait du brésil le
deuxième pays le plus endeuillé au monde
le chef de la diplomatie américaine fait
l'éloge de son allié colombien au
deuxième jour de sa tournée en amérique
latine et salue un modèle de gestion des
migrants oui près de deux millions de
personnes se sont réfugiées en colombie
pour fuir le venezuela voisin est les
états unis et la colombie à main dans la
main une fois n'est pas coutume pour
s'opposer au gouvernement vénézuélien
d'hugo chavez les explications de
juliette la nuit
après l'équateur anthony blinken
continue sa tournée sud américaine
ce mercredi il a été reçu par le
président colombien ivan du quai à
bogota objectif trouver des solutions
pour lutter contre l'insécurité en
amérique latine mais surtout évoqué les
questions migratoires un sujet essentiel
pour le secrétaire d'état américain
puisqu'il constitue l'un des défis
majeurs du continent
nous reconnaissons tous deux que le défi
migratoire sans précédent auxquels nous
sommes confrontés dans notre hémisphère
nécessite une coopération et une
coordination régionale est une
responsabilité partagée
c'est l'objet du travail que nous
faisons ensemble et je pense que nous
aurons des mesures concrètes à annoncer
pour relever ce défi plus tard dans la
journée
de son côté le président colombien a
tenu à remercier les etats-unis d'avoir
rapidement débloqué des fonds destinés à
ces enjeux migratoires mais il a surtout
évoqué la migration provenant du
venezuela
car la colombie est devenue un point de
passage pour des milliers d'haïtiens de
cubains et de vénézuéliens qui veulent
se diriger vers les états unis pour
tenter de répondre à ce problème le
président du quai a lancé cette année un
plan de régularisation de statut pour
près d'un millions de vénézuéliens sans
papiers at inc
je pense que la crise migratoire est
plus compliquée du monde qui se déroule
à lieu de cette région et c'est sans
doute la crise migratoire vénézuélienne
et nous avons vu plus de 5 millions de
personnes quittaient le pays les eaux
gelées sans accès à la nourriture et aux
médicaments et se rend dans différents
pays et de recherche d'opportunités nous
avons accueilli en colombie près de 1
million 8 de migrants venus de liens
nous avons créé un cadre politique pour
faire face à cette situation très
compliquée
les tensions récurrentes entre la
colombie et le venezuela depuis 2015 ont
entraîné la fermeture de la frontière
entre les deux pays en 2019 lorsque la
colombie et une cinquantaine d'autres
pays ont reconnu le dirigeant
d'opposition juan garrido comme
président par intérim
caracas a totalement rompu ses relations
avec bogota mais récemment les deux pays
ont c'est la réouverture de leur
frontière terrestre principalement pour
des raisons commerciales une tentative
de réchauffement qui pour l'heure reste
en suspens et de son côté le président
vénézuélien
maduro et et non pas hugo chavez comme
dit précédemment a répondu favorablement
à l'appel du sénateur de la colombie a
exprimé son désir de normaliser les
relations diplomatiques entre les deux
pays
la colombie et le venezuela nous devons
résoudre nos problèmes en t nous devons
régulariser normaliser les relations
commerciales productive et collines nous
devons normaliser les relations
consulaires diplomatique
nous applaudissons cette initiative est
en le couvant législative de la colombie
le pouvoir législatif du venezuela
grève inédite à présent aux états unis
tous secteurs confondus du jamais vu
depuis
1968 des milliers de travailleurs sont
en grève pour réclamer de meilleures
conditions de travail des salariés
épuisé par la pandémie voyez les
explications de notre correspondant à
washington comme abonnés
le mouvement a été renommé strike tauber
contraction de strike qui veut dire
grève en anglais et 2 octobre heure des
milliers de travailleurs américains sur
l'ensemble du pays ont sorti le piquet
de grève au mouvement salué par l'ale
gauche du parti démocrate
alexandria occasio cortese en tête
épuisée par près de deux ans de pandémie
les salariés ont donc décidé de s'unir
pour obtenir de meilleures conditions de
travail
illustration avec ses salariés de
kellogg célèbre vendeur de céréales
devant leur usine du des bras ce cas
ils veulent que tous les riches restent
riches et que nous restions à terre
il ya 18 mois nous étions considérés
comme des employés est essentielle notre
pdg de nous traiter de héros maintenant
quand il est temps de nous donner et à
tous les membres du syndicat un accord
équitable cela ne se produit pas
l'entreprise affirme que c'est la
première fois depuis 1972 que ces
salariés céréaliers sont en grève et
d'autres secteurs sont concernés le
domaine de la santé les fabricants de
tracteurs ou encore l'industrie
cinématographique la semaine dernière à
hollywood un accord a été trouvé évitant
de justesse une grève des équipes de
tournage alors ce mouvement s'explique
par la conjoncture économique américaine
les états unis manque de main d'oeuvre
et les salariés ont bien compris qu'ils
étaient donc en position de force il est
difficile aujourd'hui d'estimer avec
précision le nombre de grévistes sur
l'ensemble du pays mais certains
avancent le chiffre de cent mille
personnes qui seraient donc actuellement
en grève aux etats unis une chose est
sûre ce mouvement social est un fait
plutôt rare au pays du libéralisme la
pandémie ayant fait ressurgir des
frustrations chez certains salariés face
aux profits records de quelques
entreprises on assiste donc à un
phénomène de contagion et un nombre
croissant de grévistes
[Musique]
le conseil de sécurité réuni en urgence
hier après un nouveau tir de missile
confirmée par la corée du nord mais
c'est le huitième lancement en moins de
deux mois missile lancé cette fois
depuis un sous marin une surenchère à
l'armement de pyongyang pour peser sur
une éventuelle reprise de dialogue au
point mort avec washington depuis des
mois un sujet de mehdi est effectif
pas de déclaration commune mais
américains et européens sont unanimes à
la sortie du conseil de sécurité de
l'onu la corée du nord progresse dans
ses programmes d'armement convoqué en
urgence par washington et londres après
le tir inédits mardi d'un missile
balistique à partir d'un sous marin la
réunion s'est conclue sans nouvelles
sanctions vers la péninsule mais avec
des avertissements notamment américains
ichigo est permanent chacun veulent
avancer des programmes d'armes de
destruction massive et de missiles
balistiques de la corée du nord
déstabilise la région et menace la paix
et la sécurité internationales et les
états unis demandent à la corée du nord
de s'abstenir de nouvelles provocations
et de s'engager dans un dialogue soutenu
et substantielles save the date
de son côté pyongyang se défend et
accuse les etats-unis de faire deux
poids deux mesures les nord coréens
estiment que washington pratiques d
essai d'armement similaires il affirme
également que le dernier test balistique
en date ne visait pas les états unis
étaient uniquement dédiée à la défense
du pays
les etats-unis n'ont pas besoin de
s'inquiéter ou de se préoccuper de ce
tir d'essai les critiques qui porte sur
le développement et les tirs d'essai du
même système d'armement que celui que
les états unis possèdent ou développent
est une expression claire du deux poids
deux mesures
les discussions entre les deux pays sont
aujourd'hui au point mort depuis le
fiasco du sommet de hanoi en février
kim jong-un et donald trump qui
s'étaient rencontrés à trois reprises ne
sont pas parvenus à trouver un compromis
pour mettre fin au programme nucléaire
nord-coréen mais joe biden a promis de
poursuivre les efforts afin de trouver
une voie diplomatique
en grande bretagne pas de poursuites
après la clôture d'une enquête sur des
crimes de guerre présumés commis par
soldats britanniques en irak oui une
enquête sur les agissements de l'armée
britannique au cours des années 2000
lorsque londres avaient participé à
l'assaut america contre bagdad les
détails en images avec cécilia chaumont
en 2003 l'armée britannique prend part à
l'invasion de l'irak menée par une
coalition internationale dirigée par les
états unis et maintient des troupes dans
le pays jusqu'en 2009
l'anc est indépendante clos ce mardi au
royaume-uni examiner des accusations de
crimes de guerre britannique en irak
pour lesquels cinq personnes avaient été
renvoyés devant la justice en 2019
finalement d'après le ministre de la
défense aucun soldat n'a été poursuivi
les recherches menées par la police
militaire dans des conditions difficiles
sur le champ de bataille elles n'ont pas
permis d'obtenir toutes les preuves
requises de sorte que les occasions de
demander des comptes aux responsables
ont peut être été perdu les premières
plaintes de prisonniers soldats irakiens
pour abus tortures et assassinats
remonte au moins à 2004
[Musique]
ces dernières années plus de 400
prisonniers irakiens ont contacté le
centre européen pour les droits
constitutionnels et humains à berlin et
le cabinet d'avocats public interest
lawyers de birmingham pour dénoncer des
maltraitances graves et des humiliations
par des soldats britanniques
évoquant quatre condamnations de
personnels militaires britanniques
survenus avant le travail de la
commission indépendante le ministre de
la défense a présenté les excuses sans
réserves de son gouvernement à tous ceux
qui ont subi un traitement inacceptable
de la part des forces britanniques en
décembre 2012 le ministère de la défense
a annoncé avoir versé 15 millions 100
mille livres soit environ 18 millions
d'euros à plus de 200 irakiens accusant
des militaires britanniques de détention
illégale et de torture
[Musique]
allez on ouvre la page salutaire à
présent avec cette situation au maroc le
maroc qui met en place à partir
d'aujourd'hui un passeport vaccinale oui
une carte de vaccination désormais
obligatoire pour se déplacer à
l'intérieur du territoire et pour se
rendre également l'étranger impasse
aussi nécessaire pour accéder aux lieux
publics comme les hôtels les restaurants
les commerces ou encore les salles de
sport et on va en parler ce matin avec
moules et said afifi les présidents de
la société marocaine des sciences
médicales
[Musique]
moulé said affiche bonjour bonjour
bienvenue dans la matinale de rtl france
on disait le pass vaccinale obligatoire
aujourd'hui au maroc pour commencer
comment la population reçoit telle cette
obligation
de toute façon notre pays le royaume du
maroc n'instaurait le post vaccinales
après avoir obtenu puisqu'on est à plus
de 23 millions de personnes qui ont été
vaccinées donc à 78% de la population
cible et 70% plus de 21 millions pour
les deux doses donc à partir du moment
où on a ce pour ton pourcentage
important qui au cours de la dernière
vague
on a eu moins de 2 de dégâts que les
autres pays qui ne met pas cette
couverture vaccinale donc pour encore
booster cette vaccination
notre pays et notre état a pris la
décision d'instaurer deux passes
vaccinale mais ça fait plus d'un mois
qu'il y ait une compagne pour parler de
ce passé vaccinale il faut dire aussi
que concernant la vaccination des élèves
de plus de 12 ans on est à + 2 82% pour
la première dose et plus de 55% pour la
deuxième dose est là aussi pour la
troisième dose on est à plus de 800000
personnes qui ont été vaccinées par la
troisième tome des marocains qui se plie
volontiers à cette vaccination est donc
hop hassani terre comment est-ce que ça
va être mis en place est ce que c'est
sur le modèle d'une application ou d'une
autorisation qu'on doive fournir comment
ça se passe
c'est le seul le monde elles le sont en
train d'être mis sur place au monde elle
qui a été adoptée aussi chez vous avec
l'application sur le smartphone c'est en
train d'être mis en place ceci dit les
autorités ont rappelé que ça va être au
début
flexible et que les personnes qui
vendent par exemple avoir la première
dose auront aussi accès à ces lieux en
attendant qu'il puisse avoir la deuxième
dose trois semaines après donc c'est
fait la vaccination chez nous est un
acte volontaire
il faut savoir que au niveau de la
vaccination nous sommes un pays qui a
une culture de vaccination puisque pour
la vaccination des de nos enfants on est
une couverture de plus de 95% nous avons
3700 postes fixes de vaccination et plus
de dix mille
unités mobiles pour vacciner les
personnes à travers tout le pays et elle
et ça ça marche bien parce que les gens
ont vu que cette vaccination ne les
protègent contre les formes graves on
veut aussi profiter de l'accalmie que
nous avons actuellement au niveau de la
situation épidémiologique puisque nous
sommes descendus d'un taux d'occupation
de la réanimation de 50% à -2 8% et nous
sommes passés d'un taux de positivité
des tests pcr de 25 % à 3 %
alors comme on profite pour que le
maximum de personnes soient vaccinés
puisqu'on ne sait pas de quoi est fait
de l'un et le pour les personnes qui ne
souhaitent pas être vaccinés ce que le
test fonctionne pour fait office de
passes sanitaire lorsque ces personnes
veulent veulent se déplacer ou aller
dans un restaurant par exemple le test
est pris en compte
les mesures qui ont été faites n'ont
aujourd'hui le test n'est pape léon
contre on parle par contre chez vous 2
passes sanitaire mais surtout de passe
thaksin ceci dit il y à des centres qui
sont là pour les personnes qui ont des
problèmes
l'allergie pour qu'ils soient vaccinés
dans de meilleures conditions et les
personnes qui ont des contre indications
devraient de la vaccination auront un
papier pour pouvoir se déplacer le
dispositif de suffisamment de vaccins et
de quels vaccins dispose-t-il est il
question aussi d'une troisième dose
comme comme en europe
oui la troisième dose a été instaurée
sur recommandation du comité technique
de vaccination anti coup vite le 28
septembre et elle concerne les personnes
âgées les personnes qui ont des
comorbidités et les personnes de
première ligne qu'ils soient du secteur
de la santé du secteur sécuritaire ou du
de l'éducation
nationale et
ça marche bien et on a je vais vous
donner les chiffres on a par exemple les
personnes de plus de 75 ans ont eu
100% ont été vaccinées par les deux
doses les personnes de plus de 60 ans
95% les réticences qu'il y a c'est pour
la population entre 18 et 35 ans comme
ça se passe ailleurs et
voilà ces vaccins est assez de vaccins
puisque nous sommes nous avons un un
taux de vaccins actuellement nous avons
plus de 16 millions de doses dont commun
de quoi vacciner en as tu encore
l'arrivage et vous le savez que sa
majesté le roi que dieu l'assisté a
lancé la fabrication de le projet de
fabrication de vaccins le 5 juillet et
les laboratoires sothema vont pouvoir
ont fabriqué à partir de décembre à
raison de 5 millions de doses par mois 2
du vaccin si nos femmes merci beaucoup
les saillies de afif d'avoir répondu à
nos questions ce matin sur rtl france je
le rappelle vous êtes président de la
société marocaine des sciences médicales
[Musique]
l'eau passe sanitaire qui entrent aussi
en vigueur aujourd'hui en bulgarie une
mesure qu'il a n'est pas effet est loin
de faire l'unanimité puisque les
bulgares doivent désormais des présentes
et la preuve d'un schéma vaccinal
complet ou un test pcr négatif de -2 48
heures pour accéder à tous les lieux
publics en intérieur mais vous le lisiez
c'est une mesure contestée par une
partie de la population et on le voit
sur ces images pour protester contre la
mise en place du pass sanitaires un
rassemblement a eu lieu hier soir devant
le ministère de la santé à sofia ouais
hein pas sanitaire également contesté en
slovénie des centaines de manifestants
se sont réunis dans les rues de la
capitale pour dire non à cette
obligation vaccinale où il voyait et en
italie également c'est l'obligation de
présenter ce pass sanitaires pour aller
travailler qui ne passe décidément pas à
rome ils étaient quelques dizaines à
manifester dont certains grimés en tenue
de déporté rien que ça pour s'opposer à
cette mesure qui entre en vigueur à
partir de demain et ces mobilisations en
italie magali elles ont été suivies de
près par notre journaliste web fabricio
tribunaux bugatti et on va le retrouver
tout de suite pour la rubrique art et
sur le web
[Musique]
bonjour fabriquions on le disait on l'a
vu les manifestations qui se poursuivent
à trieste la situation et y est
explosive depuis quelques jours vous
vous êtes penché sur le sujet pouvez
vous nous en dire plus
alors oui en effet en fait le port de la
ville de trieste était occupé depuis
trois jours par les dockers qui était
opposé à l'imposition du pass sanitaires
mais ce blocus a été brisée lundi par
une intervention assez musclée de la
police anti émeute celle ci a notamment
utilisé des canons à eau des gaz
lacrymogènes et a aussi chargé plusieurs
fois les manifestants pour les déloger
après ces scènes d'affrontement
d'ailleurs le gouvernement a estimé
affirmé devant le parlement que les
éléments violents étaient du côté des
manifestants et non pas de la police le
gouvernement s'est aussi défendu de
vouloir jouer une stratégie de la
tension alors c'est donc la fin de
l'histoire pour ces manifestants
alors en fait l'évacuation de la police
ne les a pas tous découragés ils ont
continué à se rassembler dans le centre
ville de trieste notamment et certains y
ont même passé la nuit
la mobilisation s'est également
poursuivie le lendemain le mardi est un
mouvement citoyen a même été lancé à
cette occasion qui s'appelle cordina
mento queen des chiffres diadji alors le
nom fait référence sont faites au
premier jour du blocus du port le 15
octobre mais aussi à l'entrée en vigueur
du pass sanitaires pour se rendent au
travail le même jour son mot d'ordre est
très sain tu sais nous ne reculerons pas
d'un pouce
symptomatique de ce qui se passe en
italie
en fait trieste a la particularité aussi
d'incarner l'épicentre de la résistance
anti pas sanitaire en italie le 9
octobre dernier il y avait déjà quinze
mille manifestants qui s'étaient
rassemblés pour cette seule ville de
nombreuses grèves et manifestations ont
aussi eu lieu dans toute la péninsule
vous avez cité rome avant mais il est
aussi gênes ou venise et même des
conseillers régionaux du latium
s'étaient enfermés dans leur bureau en
guise de protestation contre le passé ni
terre imposé pour se rendre sur le lieu
de travail
merci beaucoup fabrizzio tribu duo
bugatti pour toutes ces précisions on
peut lire à vos articles sur ce sujet
sur notre site est référence point tva
[Musique]
et en france la prolongation du pass and
i ter a été adopté de justesse à
l'assemblée la nuit dernière après des
débats houleux les députés ont voté en
faveur du projet loi vigilance sanitaire
avec seulement dix voix d'écart 1 135 %
25 contre et concernant l'article de
insu lui sur la prolongation du pass
vaccinale il a été approuvé à une petit
doigt près le projet de loi doit
maintenant être examiné par le sénat à
elle dès la semaine prochaine les
rassemblements de soutien d'ailleurs ce
matin aux professionnels de santé
suspendu pour non vaccination une
manifestation qui a lieu devant le siège
de l'ap-hp à paris un mois après
l'entrée en vigueur de l'obligation
vaccinale pour les personnels soignants
quinze mille d'entre eux ont été
suspendus depuis le 15 septembre dernier
selon le ministère de la santé et pour
plus de précision on va retrouver tout
de suite notre reporter estelle farges
[Musique]
bonjour estelle alors quel est le mot
d'ordre de ce rassemblement
est bien olivier tout simplement exiger
la réintégration des personnels de santé
de l'ap-hp suspendu car non vaccinés
chez un rassemblement à l'appel de
l'usap cgt à l'union syndicale de
l'assistance publique est des soignants
qui compte non seulement dénoncer leur
suspension mais aussi est l'impact de
cette mesure sur les services de santé
pour eux il s'agit tout simplement d'une
situation paradoxale puisque d'un côté
il y à des personnels de santé qui
souhaitent conserver leur emploi et de
l'autre une loi qui leur interdit de
travailler alors que les services manque
de personnel elle s'est en tout cas ce
qu'on a pu lire dans un communiqué de
l'usap cgt
et justement estelle on en sait un peu
plus maintenant sur le nombre de
soignants qui ne sont pas encore
vaccinés
[Musique]
et oui magali sur les 2,2 millions de
professionnels de santé que compte le
pays il était un peu plus de 288 mille à
avoir reçu à n'avoir reçu aucune dose au
15 septembre date de l'entrée en vigueur
de l'obligation vaccinale pour les
personnels soignants au 6 octobre
dernier ils n'étaient plus que 129000 à
ne pas être vaccinés de son côté le
ministère de la santé a fait état de
quinze mille suspension à ce qui
pourrait signifier que parmi les non
suspendues et les noms enfin les
suspendus et les non vaccinés certains
sont en congé ou en arrêt maladie ou
alors qu'ils ont tout simplement
bénéficié d'une certaine tolérance de
leur établissement merci beaucoup et ce
talent pour toutes ces précisions vous
allez suivre pour nous ce rassemblement
aujourd'hui pour vrt france et estelle
farges donc en direct devant l'ap-hp à
partie
[Musique]
et on en vient à la crise de l'énergie à
présent avec cette situation en france
où probablement un chèque carburant
serait la piste privilégiée par le
gouvernement pour faire face à la hausse
des prix de l'essence oui c'est en tout
cas la piste privilégiée par le ministre
de l'économie des mesures doivent être
annoncées 1 d'ici vendredi par
l'exécutif bruno le maire a plaidé hier
soir pour la mise en place d'un chèque
carburant plutôt que la baisse des taxes
très coûteuses sur le long terme selon
lui secte est
la deuxième grande famille d'options
c'est de dire on va faire quelque chose
de plus ciblée ça touchera pas tous les
français mais ce sera peut-être plus
juste parce que c'est touchera ceux qui
sont les plus modestes ce qu'on dirait
deux niveaux de revenus moyens et nous
allons compenser en tout ou en partie on
regardera ça le choc ça représente pour
le pouvoir d'achat des personnes qui
viennent de s'exprimer qui vont à la
pompe et qui 10,60 euros à payer pour un
plein c'est trop c'est une autre famille
d'options qui peut être ciblée sur les
gens qui travaillent sur les gens je les
vois dans ma circonscription d habiter à
evreux vous travaillez à paris il faut
faire 95 km à la les 95 au retour ça
vous coûte très cher en carburant je
vois des chômeurs qui cherchent un
emploi qui ont besoin de leur voiture
pour chercher l'emploi je vois des
indépendants qui travaillent dans le
bâtiment dont les travaux publics qui
l'yonne les routes de mon département
avec des camionnettes ça leur coûte cher
aussi moi je pense que c'est aujourd'hui
la solution qui est à la fois la plus
juste et la plus efficace du point de
vue environnemental et avec cette hausse
des carburants du prix des carburants
des gilets jaunes étaient de retour sur
les ronds points le week-end dernier une
grande sociale qui s'ajoute à celle
contre le pass annie terre alors les
mouvements peuvent-ils converger on en
parle tout de suite avec notre
éditorialiste nicolas vidal c l'édito
politique de la matinale
[Musique]
nicolas bonjour bonjour à vous bonjour
nicolas heureux de vous retrouver ce
matin sur rtl france on lisait un
nouveau mouvement des gilets jaunes qui
sont revenus sur les ronds points le
week-end dernier qu'est ce qu'on peut
retenir de cette mobilisation ah ben on
va en retirer victimes en léger les
jeunes ont fait leur retour ce samedi
dernier sur de nombreux ronds points
partout en france pour protester contre
huk contre le prix exorbitant des
carburants c'est cette même est un c'est
râpé vous qui avait mis le feu aux
poudres populaire en novembre 2018 pour
ouvrir ce mouvement historique longue de
plusieurs mois alors le premier il avait
été réglé avec beaucoup lacrymogènes de
tir du lb des deux blessés graves de
garde à vue et de comparution immédiate
mais revoilà loger les jeunes et
bizarrement les médias main stream n'ont
presque pas évoquer cet appel national
en amont pourtant le hashtag gilet jaune
saison 2 avait occupé les tendances de
twitter france pendant quelques heures
en fin de semaine dernière mais
peut-être que certains médias parisiens
n'avaient pas eu l'information à temps
et si c'est le cas il faudrait quand
même penser à changer les vieux minitel
poussiéreux les antennes réseau fixe et
sur le toit ou alors c'est simplement la
bonne vieille méthode coué de si on n'en
parle pas il n'existe pas mais par
contre dès dimanche matin certains
médias totalement muet à ce sujet était
déjà sur le couple où venir que la
mobilisation des jeunes et jeunes
avaient été très timides samedi pour cet
appel national même les titres santé la
jubilation de celui qui sans vous dire
est bien fait et tac encore loupé celle
là qui l'a pas volé néanmoins il semble
que le comportement bobo médiatique aux
écolos mondiale au parisien soit un peu
hâtif et je vais prendre deux exemples
qui devrait faire réfléchir le
gouvernement par exemple à montpellier
la manifestation contre le passé ni
terre a rejoint pour la première fois
samedi les gilet jaune sur le rond point
du quartier près d'arènes dans le sud de
la ville
ajoutez à cela l'exemple ce qui se passe
actuellement à trieste en italie depuis
plusieurs jours ainsi que dans d'autres
villes royalement occultée par nos chers
médias main stream qui pourrait donner
des idées ici en france à certains alors
laissez donc entendre nicolas que ces
deux mouvements pourraient converger ben
oui on peut le on peut l'estimer et bien
au vu de la situation de plus en plus
apocalyptique que traverse la france du
gouvernement du sous secrétaire de
préfecture le charismatique jean castex
mais plus d'enthousiasmé à hacher menu
les droits au chômage à raboter les
retraites et à faire payer les pays r et
les antigénique qu'à prendre en compte
le courroux populaire qui ne cesse de
grandir chaque jour un peu plus c'est en
réalité cher ami le grand schelem des
mauvaises idées dans lesquels dans
laquelle il faut s'armer d'incompétence
et de langue de bois car la langue de
bois elle sert justement à masquer
l'incompétence et surtout le néant alors
pourquoi magazine convergence d'un côté
les mesures sanitaires qui devait
s'arrêter dans la seconde où la
situation s'améliorer devrait se
poursuivre jusqu'à l'été 2022 ça aucun
contrôle parlementaire avouez que cela
ça fait une très très très longues
secondes et maintenant on réfléchit au
gouvernement à ce que le pass annie
terre puisse inclure une troisième dose
de vaccin donc les 12 vacciner
repartirait à la case départ sans passer
encore par la case prison cela pourrait
être suffisamment hainard pour énerver
quelques centaines de milliers de
vacciner qui pourrait avoir un sens de
l'humour de plus en plus approximatif
avec des fulgurances sanitaire d'olivier
la science du moins on l'espère sans
compter que payer pour les tests
commencent à ressembler de plus en plus
à des amendes déguisée de l'autre côté
vous avez la tribu des pieds nickelés
avec bruno le maire barbara pompili et
jean castex qui tente de trouver un truc
pour faire baisser les tarifs des
carburants sans baisser les taxes de
l'état là on touche au ridicule mais au
gouvernement il appelle cela des
arbitrages c'est comme une sorte de
consignes d'actionnaires où tout le
monde tout le monde finalement garde ses
mains dans ses poches en refusant de
remettre un billet de 20 alors que
dehors des milliers de français font
tous les jours des équations à quadriple
inconnu où il faut choisir entre aller
bosser aller faire ses courses ou aller
promener ses gamins et nicolas est ce
que la possible conjonction de ces
contestations pourrait prendre de
l'ampleur dans les jours à venir et bien
ce matin il s'agit de se poser les
bonnes questions en charge et demi alors
que reste-t-il aux français alors que
sur leur carte d'identité il n'y a pu
inscrire est plus française mais
république de l'état d'urgence orné d'un
qr code que reste t-il aux français
lorsque l'assemblée nationale où il n'y
a que 170 députés présents sur un texte
aussi important pour l'article 1 que
reste-t-il aux français lorsque 380
députés ne daigne pas assisté à la chute
de notre démocratie eh bien ils le
restent emmanuelle wargon qui veut
pourfendre les maisons individuelles
lotissement depuis son pavillon cossu de
la banlieue parisienne car cette vitesse
est un non sens écologique
le reste aussi emmanuel macron qui fait
du foot entre des soignants qui tire des
penaltys et qui est à un orteil de ce
trou proclamé ballon d'or sous le regard
bienveillant de riches de mâcon qui est
venu lui apporter des belles et les
compotes ayant ne parlera même pas leur
troisième mi-temps sans gestes barrières
hormis pour le petit personnel en
réalité depuis les gilet jaune il ne
reste plus grand chose aux français
épris de liberté pour se faire entendre
et pour contester dans les nuages de gaz
lacrymogènes
en réalité des millions de français sont
pris en otage sous le poids d'un pouvoir
de plus en plus liberticides il ya en
réalité des millions de français n'ont
aujourd'hui plus aucune confiance dans
leur assemblée nationale à cause des
députés qui l'ont élu et qui ne sont pas
à l'assemblée aujourd'hui les miens de
fond c'est son seul face à la politique
brutale des manuels macron qui a réussi
son pari divisés comme jamais et il faut
relire toujours en arène qui écrivait je
cite les mouvements totalitaires sont
des organisations massim d'individus
atomisés est isolé il faut lire le
dernier livre de françois hollande aux
siens si on veut en apprendre plus sur
et bien exactement et celui de gérard
davet et fabrice lhomme le très très
haut et en très bon bouquin merci
beaucoup nicolas c'était l'édito
politique ne la matinale
[Musique]
et on va à versailles à présent une
course-poursuite dégénère et bla sept
policiers des coups de feu ont également
été tirés les faits se sont déroulés
hier dans la matinée un homme au volant
d'une voiture a pris la fuite après
avoir refusé un contrôle de police la
bac l'a aussitôt pris en chasse le
fuyard a tenté de s'échapper en
percutant deux voitures de police sept
fonctionnaires ont été blessés un des
policiers a dû tirer dans les roues du
véhicule pour l'immobiliser
[Musique]
et on ouvre la page politique à présent
avec cette question à six mois de la
présidentielle la droite est-elle retard
dans la campagne alors que le polémiste
eric zemmour lui est sur tous les fronts
et toujours pas déclaré officiellement
candidat et oui le polémiste qui s'est
fait remarquer hier au salon de
l'armement vous le voyez salon de
l'armement milipol à villepinte en
brandissant un fusil d'assaut qui a fait
pas mal réagir la veille il était à
versailles avec les sympathisants de la
manif pour tous un électorat
traditionnel passionnément et l'air et
les républicains vous voyez qui eux ont
affiché une unité sans faille devant les
photographes avant-hier lors d'un petit
déjeuner les six candidats au congrès
des quatre du 4 novembre ont convenu
d'ailleurs d'organiser un débat par
semaine au préalable le prouver le 8
novembre prochain et côté christian
jacob
n'ont cessé c'est un pack d'organisation
de l'équipe de france pour gagner la
présidentielle
donc on est dans ce sujet de bien
entendu chacun a sa personnalité son
identité ses sensibilités et ça va être
d'ailleurs tout l'intérêt d'avoir les
débats les échanges dans les fédérations
mais c'est aussi de construire le
rassemblement et la campagne à droite on
en parle avec yves nicolin ce matin mer
les républicains de roanne et valentin
blé lee responsable départemental des
déjeuners l'air dans le loiret soutien
d'eric zemmour
[Musique]
bonjour à tous les deux merci beaucoup
d'être en direct avec nous ce matin sur
rtl pour débattre de la campagne à
droite ce matin avec cette photo rue de
vaugirard des tout sourire les six
candidats à l'investiture et l'air et
l'annoncent de quatre débats devant le
contrat est ce que la campagne les
républicains à commencer véritablement
je commence par vous il nicolas
oui je pense que la campagne est en
route en tout cas c'est un ordre de
bataille qui se prépare
nous avons aujourd'hui donc un process
donc pour désigner le futur candidat
donc des républicains et donc des
candidats qui se sont ralliés à ce
procès ce pour quoi qu'il arrive le 4
décembre nous aurons un candidat la
question qui peut se poser c'est de
savoir est ce que ça ne sera pas trop
tard aujourd'hui ce que j'observe c'est
que on parle de beaucoup de candidats
qui sont en campagne ou qui ne sont pas
déclarés et pour l'instant d'une
sûrement retard sur personne puisque
hormis marine le pen personne n'est
candidat officiellement déclaré on joue
sur les moins écoutés scanner georges
fenech d'ailleurs à ce propos anciens
membres à l'est républicain
je crois que les républicains cherchent
toujours elle cherche toujours un
candidat qui soit une alternative
possible mais le processus de
désignation est beaucoup trop long ils
doivent essayer de rattraper le retard
et ça va être compliqué mais l'élection
se jouera dans les dernières semaines à
la campagne ne commencera vraiment qu'en
février
donc ce n'est pas trop tard l'expérience
nous a montré que tout n'est pas encore
joué on va en parler les républicains
qui soit peut-être un petit peu en
retard valentin blé lait à eric zemmour
lui est partout on l'a vu est ce que
c'est pas trop tôt pour le coup
non c'est non je pense pas que ce soit
trop tôt
déjà pour l'instant ça a été précisé
eric zemmour n'est pas encore quand il a
pour l'instant il fait dédicacer son
livre il fait la tournée des différentes
villes en france et
donc du coup ils présentent ils
présentent un peu ses idées ses constats
on a déjà entendu
quand il était sur six news et à la télé
et oui il est partout parce que a
aujourd'hui eric zemmour c'est un petit
peu la voix à droite qui portent parce
que c'est une droite de conviction
c'est pour l'instant le seul aussi qui
rectum du rpr les autres candidats chez
les leurs ne serait quand même plus du
rpr ne serait quand même plus la droite
traditionnelle la droite de conviction
la droite gaulliste et c'est là dessus
qu'ils récusent amour capitalise
réponse et il nicolas où vous vous en
pensez quoi
d'abord une la droite rpr pour moi qui
suis pourtant un ancien ça ne veut pas
dire grand chose aujourd'hui aux
nouvelles générations
moi même je suis je n'ai jamais été issu
du rpr j'ai participé donc à l'ump j'en
ai même été à l'un des deux chocs
étaient à l'origine maintenant le shom
donc au sein des républicains la
question n'est pas là la question c'est
qu'est ce qu'on défend comme philosophie
quelles sont les propositions qu'on va
présenter aux français pour les cinq ans
qui viennent eric zemmour est quelqu'un
qui effectivement est brillant
intelligent quelqu'un qui sait débattre
qui fait un constat qui appuient sur des
points qui font mal et donc beaucoup de
français se reconnaissent là dedans mais
pour l'instant les réponses aux
questions les propositions pour réformer
la france on ne les connaît pas pas plus
d'ailleurs que chez les candidats
aujourd'hui qui s'affiche pour les
républicains mais ça c'est le moment de
la préparation de la campagne
aujourd'hui nous avons plusieurs
candidats à la candidature chez les
républicains ils seront désignés donc le
4 décembre mais nous sommes aujourd'hui
à six mois d'élections si on regarde les
scores qu'avaient les candidats y
compris à la dernière élection
présidentielle personne n'aurait misé un
kopeck sur l'élection d' emmanuel macron
au moins d'octobre 2010 9 donc nous nous
personnes nées en retard personne n'est
en avance comme il s'était rappelée par
george clooney l'élection elle va se
jouer en février donc aujourd'hui
certain son haut dans les sondages
certains sont bas mais ce n'est pas le
résultat de la présidentielle alors on
va écouter justement valérie pécresse
qui était en saône et loire vous parliez
de d'eric zemmour qui a une voix qui
porte on voit que valérie pécresse aussi
va avoir une voix qui porte regardez je
crois que le président macron a été
inspiré par machiavel vous le savez vous
connaissez cette fameuse phrase de
machiavel machiavel disait gouverner
c'est faire croire moi je crois que
gouverner c'est agir ou gouverner c'est
faire tout simplement il nicolas elle
n'y est pas allé de main morte c'est
quoi la cible c'est emmanuel macron plus
que eric zemmour pour l'instant
il écope d'accord il est évident pardon
quand on est candidat à l'élection
présidentielle vous avez un sortant qui
s'appelle emmanuel macron bien sûr que
nous sommes là pour remplacer manuel
mâcon donc la cible principale reste
effectivement emmanuel macron d'autant
plus qu emmanuel macron a axé toute son
action politique pour dire en même temps
je suis de droite je suis de gauche sauf
qu'on se rend compte qu'il n'est ni l'un
ni l'autre il est effectivement ailleurs
et surtout très loin des préoccupations
des français prenez ce débat sur
l'augmentation aujourd'hui donc des
carburants les propositions nous les
attendons mais une fois de plus on
risque de sombrer dans des propositions
qui ne vont concerner qu'une infime
minorité de français nous ce que nous
attendons ce sont des propositions qui
contient tous les français alors on va
perdre et justement vous parlez de
l'année d'après
la principale préoccupation qui reste le
pouvoir d'achat on l'a vu dans un
sondage hier eric zemmour lui pendant ce
temps là ils étaient annulés paul on va
regarder l'image valentin embellie
d'ailleurs il a été critiqué eric
zemmour pour avoir
brandi un fusil d'assaut est-ce que
c'est pas un petit peu à côté des
préoccupations du moment valentin davis
ce déplacement à milipol
non je ne pense pas absolument pas parce
que la france a quand même vécu un
certain nombre d'événements qui sont des
attentats terroristes on en parle encore
on parle de ce qui s'est passé avec sa
mére pâtit également
assez dans la tête de tous les français
il rencontre un hommage a pas si
longtemps que ça
c'est un véritable c'est vraiment
anxieux pour les français les français
ont peur pour leur sécurité
et justement eric zemmour se déplace et
monk et s'intéresse à tous les sujets
qui s'intéressent à la sécurité
intérieure à l'immigration aussi à la
défense il s'intéresse aussi à à
l'économie s'intéresse à l'éducation
elle a beaucoup parlé d'éducation
récemment
entendu parler de pouvoir d'achat eric
zemmour qu'en pense-t-elle
alors après évidemment il ya énormément
de sujets qui touchent la france tu ça
va venir probablement petit à petit pour
l'instant il parle des sujets doute il
envie de parler est la preuve que ce
sont les sujets des plus importants
actuellement puisque tous une part de
lui donc
alors effectivement tout part de lui on
a on a vu cet électorat et l'air très
courtisé par eric zemmour avant-hier
puisqu'il était à versailles c'est le
fief de françois xavier bellamy
opération séduction chez les catholiques
conservateurs de la manif pour tous
l'ancien électorat fillonniste selon
eric zemmour il faut allier la
bourgeoisie patriotes qui est sûr
représentés dans l'assemblée au casse
populaire que qui elles sont absentes
écoutez le
il faut allier la sociologie de la manif
pour tous et la sociologie des gilet
jaune la manif pour tous en majorité
bourgeoise a échoué parce que les
classes populaires ils sont restés
étrangères il faut trouver des axes qui
rassemble ces deux sociologie le sujet
qui rassemble c'est la question au sens
large identitaire et de l'immigration
les autres combats ne sont pas moins
importants mais vont nous faire perdre
yves nicolin clairement eric moore
essaie de rallier ces déçus de la manif
pour tous
jeux surtout l'impression qu'eric
zemmour il est dans la tactique il n'est
pas sûr qu est ce que je peux faire pour
mon pays pour effectivement préparer ce
dernier donc aux grands enjeux
internationaux et et et nationaux donc
maintenant il ya une tactique de
campagne qui effectivement décidé de
capter un électorat
je pense aujourd'hui que les français ne
sont pas de lui mais c'est un peu la
tactique aussi d'avoir des voix pour
voter pour soi non mais avant d'avoir
des voix aux élections c'est au mois
d'avril avant d'aller chercher ces voix
aujourd'hui il faut qu'on connaisse le
corpus c'est à dire la volonté de chaque
candidat qu'est ce qu'il veut pour son
pays aujourd'hui nous avons un corpus
idéologique sheller qui très connus on
en parle depuis des décennies maintenant
nous attendons si la sensibilité de
chaque candidat sur des propositions
donc notamment sur la société mais
ramener effectivement la campagne
uniquement la sécurité serait une erreur
on a effectivement des problèmes de
pouvoir d'achat on a les poils de
sécurité on n'avait pas une
d'immigration on est des pointes de
santé on a des problèmes d'emploi
aujourd'hui je vous raconte juste un
exemple en ce qui concerne la ville mais
nous avons sur mon arrondissement six
mille demandeurs d'emploi or nous avons
trois mille offres d'emploi non pourvues
quand que fait-on pour faire en sorte
que nous ayons 3000 chômeurs de moins
alors que c'est possible parce que nous
avons trois mille offres d'emploi sur
mon territoire aujourd'hui nous avons un
vrai problème sur comment remettre
certains demandeurs d'emploi au travail
alors qu'il ya des offres de travail et
pas des offres factice de vraies offres
avec une bonne paye donc tu dire c'est
un vrai problème aujourd'hui nous avons
aussi donc des sujets de pouvoir d'achat
c'est évident et ça veut dire qu'il faut
travailler sur qu'est ce qu'on fait pour
redonner le pouvoir d'achat est ce que
ça passe par une baisse de charges
sociales est ce que ça passe par des
chèques comme le propose le gouvernement
donc tout cela doit être dans le débat
de la présidentielle plutôt que de me
parler que de quelques sujets qui certes
sont intéressants s'ils sont des
préoccupations de certaines personnes ne
correspondent pas aux aspirations de
tous valentin de l'ailier un commentaire
sur le ralliement des classes
bourgeoises avec avec les classes
populaires c'est la bonne stratégie
selon vo et ça empiète évidemment sur
l'électorat les républicains
évidemment ça va stratégie puisque c'est
comme ça qu'elles gagnent et jacques
chirac c'est comme ça qu'elles gagnent
et nicolas sarkozy c'est à la fois un
l'alliance de la droite traditionnelle
de conviction et de les classes
populaires ah oui c'est ce qu'il faut
faire et je dirais ils n'empiètent pas
sur sur l'électorat et l'air puisque
c'est l'électorat elle est en fait eric
zemmour c'est la droite normal c'est la
droite traditionnelle
c'est la droite de nourrissons pas on la
tendance est là les comparer et elle l'a
rapproché de marine le pen n'a tort
selon vous ah oui non mais c'est c c'est
tout à fait à tort eric zemmour ans il
n'a pas varié il est toujours dans ses
idées il assume ce qu'il dit il dit ce
qu'il pense et ça les français ils
l'aiment ils aiment ça ils en ont marre
de voir
tout un tas de deux personnes voilà
s'excuser s'auto flageller
de betty disent quelque chose
qui va un peu à l'encontre de la
bien-pensance et eric zemmour s'est
totalement l'averse il assume tout et il
est de droite il n'est pas de droite
radicale ou je ne sais quoi c'est encore
une fois la droite normal la droite
traditionnelle alors les selon les
chiffres communiqués justement par le
party les républicains et les adhésions
ont augmenté de 16 et demi pour cent ces
20 derniers jours depuis l'annnonce de
de ce congrès le 4 décembre prochain
qu'est-ce que ça traduit selon vous yves
nicolin les personnes
s'inscrivent pour pouvoir aller voter
puisque je rappelle que le congrès est
ouvert aux seuls adhérents
bien sûr je voulais moi je le vis est
également dans mon département jusqu'à
présent on était un peu dans le
brouillard en ce qui concerne la
présidentielle est ce que les
républicains allaient avoir un candidat
comment allait-il être désigné
aujourd'hui on sait que les républicains
vont avoir un candidat on sait la façon
dont ils vont être désignés d'opter les
français ont la feuille de route en ce
qui nous concerne et c'est ce qui fait
que beaucoup d'anciens militants dossier
adhérents ont décidé de repartir au
charbon de ré adhérer pour pouvoir
participer à ce processus nous ne sommes
pas pour un candidat autoproclamé on l'a
vu que ça n'a pas fonctionné avec
isabella à l'écran les vins liée au
district
alors je sais pas si vous me parler mais
avant les six candidats à l'investiture
à l'écran voilà donc on a six candidats
donc effectivement vous en avait
quelques-uns qui semble être en
meilleure posture que le noir nous
verrons bien l'essentiel c'est que les
militants puissent s'exprimer choisir le
candidat qui souhaite voir arriver en
tout cas être sur la ligne de départ
d'un an de la présidentielle et après
tout le monde se mettra en ordre de
marche ce qui donnera une vraie
légitimité même si effectivement ce
n'est que la légitimité d'un parti
politique mais pas moins que lorsque en
marche va demain désigner son candidat
qui sera emmanuel macron pas moins que
lorsque monsieur mélenchon réunit sept
lots pour s'auto désigner lui-même donc
comme koné en présentiel ou pas moins
que les amis de d'eric zemmour on devait
lui apporter son soutien quand il
déclare à sa candidature donc nous
sommes dans un processus où sur la vème
république ce sont les partis politiques
qui effectivement concourent à
l'expression du suffrage universel et
qui vont me permettre de
d'identifier des candidats qui seront
ensuite proposés aux français alors
justement on connaît les mieux placés
valérie pécresse xavier bertrand et
michel barnier lui qui serait très
populaire auprès des jeunes et l'air
apparemment à 50 jours du congrès sa
stature internationale et sa loyauté
sans faille séduit ses grosses
fédérations que représentent les jeunes
aient l'air onze mille adhérents ont
regardé
le ministre des affaires étrangères
commissaire européen négociateur pour le
brésil aujourd'hui quand on le voit on
se dit oui cet homme peut-être sur le
ronde de l'elysée les jeunes militants
sont très à cheval sur la question de la
fidélité au parti il travaille de
manière bénévole pour leur famille
politique se lève très tôt et se couche
très tard pour aller coller des affiches
pour aller distribuer des tracts michel
barnier incarne cette fidélité valentin
blé lait je vous pose à vous d'abord la
question parce que cette question la
fidélité on l'a entendu beaucoup chez
chez les jeunes qui soutiennent eric
zemmour c'est une des raison d'ailleurs
pour laquelle ils ont quitté souvent le
les républicains pour se tourner vers
eric zemmour le fait que xavier bertrand
ou valérie pécresse ont travaillé entre
guillemets le parti même si vous repris
leur carte et l'air depuis
moi je suis toujours républicain je suis
toujours dans le parti j'ai toujours ma
carte d'ailleurs beaucoup de personnes
qui aujourd'hui soutient eric zemmour
sont toujours chez les républicains
effectivement vous avez montré tout à
l'heure les photos des candidats - dont
il manque des candidats ou et laurent
wauquiez ou souhaits du génial aubert où
est mon nouveau retailleau oui eric
zemmour qui aurait pu être aussi
candidat je trouve que cette primaire
c'est un peu c'est la primaire de 2016
nour abbés on va être moins de votants
que pour la primaire europe ecologie les
verts
bon c'est pour créer une dynamique ça va
être compliqué vous parlez de de michel
barnier qui est fidèle à son parti c'est
très bien mais est-ce qu'il est fidèle à
ses convictions je ne suis pas sur ce
qui était quand même encore il ya
quelques années pour une europe fédérale
aujourd'hui bon il a l'air de plutôt
prendre un tournant souverainiste si je
veux dire ah bon on peut changer d'avis
évidemment il n'y a pas de problème moi
je pense que les l'air ont raté la
préparation de cette primaire ils ont vu
faire une primaire ouverte la plus
ouverte possible au niveau des candidats
au niveau des bd des électeurs sera plus
créé une dynamique là maintenant on
arrête zavier bertrand qui est bas dans
les sondages michel barnier qui en tout
inversement on à eric zemmour qui est le
seul candidat à droite
qui peut se qualifier au second tour
être face à mâcon sinon ce sera marine
le pen si c'est pas zemmour ce sera
marine le pen c'est ça la réalité c'est
que cette primaire ne sert à rien en
fait elle sert juste à désigner soit le
premier ministre de d'emmanuel bâton
soit ben je sais pas ce qu'ils vont
faire ensuite parce que des il faut
savoir qu'ils ont une cause a été mis en
place pour des violences a toutefois
évalué évidemment une élection est une
grande inconnue par définition je laisse
le mot de la fin nicolas puisqu'il nous
reste une minute pour réagir à ce que
vous venez de dire
oui moi je d'abord je rappelle
simplement que cette élection elle n'est
pas fait encore nous avons encore six
mois et ceux qui sont aujourd'hui ou
dans les sondages seront peut-être on
peut être disparu donc quelques mois
aujourd'hui moi je répète les choses la
primaire ouverte c'était la grande
arnaque du siècle on l'a vu moi je les
ai vus dans ma ville où des gens de
gauche sont venus voter pour éliminer le
candidat droite qui ne voulait pas et
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
eu une primaire qui a été vraiment
complètement différente notamment le
plan des résultats on a bien vu que et
son âge là encore lui donner certains
gagnants la primaire n'ont pas été
vérifiés donc moi je dis à notre année
rend donc des républicains prudence
c'est bien d'avoir effectivement donc
une conviction aujourd'hui on verra ce
qu'elle voudra demain il faut surtout
être prudent et se rappeler du processus
de désignation des candidats à
l'élection présidentielle ce n'est
jamais celui qu'on croit qu'ils étaient
lus ils ont par conséquent si la réserve
beaucoup de surprises et on verra cela à
l'issue donc des quatre débats qui
seront organisés le congrès pour le 4
novembre et peut-être faire un débat
avec eric zemmour dans la foulée merci
beaucoup pour avoir participé à ce débat
en direct dans la matinale de rtl france
si vous et c'est la fin de cette
première partie de la matinale on se
retrouve dans quelques petites minutes
ceux restés avec nous
[Musique]
chacun prétend détenir la vérité trop
souvent il ne s'agit que de spéculations
[Musique]
la violence peut déstabiliser la société
trop de sécurité de mettre en danger nos
libertés
[Musique]
président à vie à en perdre la vie
pascal affi n'guessan quelles sont les
raisons qui poussent les chefs d'état à
se maintenir au pouvoir en effet ce
n'est pas seulement parce que ses chefs
ont baissé de tendance cette volonté de
rester mais ça passe car en face il n'y
a pas de honte le pouvoir suffisamment
fort et le premier contre le pouvoir ces
de plus pourquoi l'organisation
d'élections transparentes reste toujours
un défi sur le continent africain était
encore beaucoup de pays à appliquer une
forte proportion de la population qui a
attaché à la question ethnique qui ne
sont pas encore acquises à la démocratie
est ce que vous serez candidat en 2025
et est ce que si vous deviez l'emporter
vous promettez justement de ne jamais
briguer un troisième mandat s'il est
volé mais pas tué et 50 cc c'est le
temps qu'il faudra
pour qu'un seul mandat on retient sa
promesse à pascal affi n'guessan
[Musique]
la problématique des déchets est apparue
au milieu du xxème siècle de nos jours
l'humanité produit plus de 2 milliards
de tonnes de déchets chaque année
on appelle cela la couche mondial de
déchets
si vous regardez autour de vous quelque
part en dehors des villes vous verrez
une colline d'ordures
les gens pollue de plus en plus la terre
et les océans gaspille l'eau brûlent des
combustibles fossiles détruisent faune
et flore
il est donc tout à fait possible qu'on
ait appuyé sur la détente s'est
déclenché un processus
c'est ce que nous ne comprenons toujours
pas pleinement
qu'arrivera-t-il à la terre lors de
cette nouvelle ère de l'humanité
[Musique]
et
y'a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sort du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave est ce que c'est
normal si on veut sauver la vie sur
terre il est probable qu'il faille
prendre un certain nombre de mesures un
peu autoritaire c'est intéressant on
comprend que vous soyez des sous les
libéraux l'uniforme c'est quand même des
hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inouï tg les gens ne
s'étaient des valeurs de droite c'était
des gens qui travaillent c'est des gens
qui avaient envie de transmettre quelque
chose à leurs enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas la ligue
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est on dirait qu il y a quand
même la liberté je vous remercie de
m'avoir invité
[Musique]
je n'oserais pas aller en ville parce
que s'ils me voyait comme ça il pourrait
l'envoyer à l'hôpital n'est ce pas
dont certaines femmes se marient à
l'étranger moi je me suis mariée à un
homme qui vit de l'autre côté de la
frontière de la réalité je vis dans un
monde fantastique car mon mari est un
magicien
[Musique]
je me suis installé dans cette forêt et
maintenant je suis forestiers comme
hagrid
j'ai réalisé que le seul endroit qui
puisse me convenir était comme dans un
conte de fées une forêt un sanctuaire
inaccessible où je pourrais vivre en
harmonie et m'imprégner de
l'environnement
[Musique]
et il est 8h à paris bienvenue dans la
deuxième partie de cette même liberté
bonjour à tous à la une de l'actualité
ce matin comment faire des c
prix de l'énergie pour les consommateurs
réunis en sommet aujourd'hui et demain à
bruxelles lé 27 pays européens vont
tenter de trouver des solutions alors
qu'ils sont très divisés sur une
stratégie commune la présidente de la
commission a déjà averti cette crise de
l'énergie ne doit pas être une excuse
pour retarder la transition écologique
le pouvoir d'achat principales
préoccupations des français en ce moment
avec la hausse du prix de l'essence
baisse des taxes ou chèque carburant
l'exécutif n'a toujours pas tranché même
si le chèque est censé plutôt la piste
privilégiée pour l'instant mais des
annonces en tout cas très attendue par
les automobilistes une crise qui a
relancé d'ailleurs là la mobilisation
des gilets jaunes samedi dernier et
d'autres manifestations sont déjà
prévues ce week-end en avoir
[Musique]
c'est la question qui préoccupe une
bonne partie des consommateurs en europe
comment faire baisser la facture
d'énergie alors que les prix des
carburants a qu'un des records et oui
une problématique qui sera au coeur des
discussions du sommet européen à partir
d'aujourd'hui alors que chacun des pays
membres tentent de mettre en place des
solutions au niveau national regarder on
fait le point avec sébastien rabat
face à la flambée des prix de l'énergie
les européens se tournent vers leurs
gouvernements respectifs
alors qu'en france les prix de l'essence
et du gasoil bat des records dans
l'ensemble du continent toutes les
contre mesures pour protéger les
consommateurs sont envisagés en
allemagne où la taxe de 54% sur le sans
plomb 95 est parmi les plus élevés du
continent les autorités au visage de la
revoir à la baisse mais cela reste pure
spéculation
le successeur d'angela merkel n'est
toujours pas en poste et juste ici
aucune mesure n'a été prise le
gouvernement sortant se veut rassurant
et prévient que des actions seront
menées si la hausse des prix se poursuit
le royaume-uni envisage de suivre la
même piste que berlin mais doit faire
face à un double problème une hausse des
prix du carburant aggravé par une
pénurie de chauffeurs routiers ces
dernières semaines à la suite du bric
site le gouvernement croate a quant à
lui déjà réagi en adoptant un décret
pour plafonner les prix du carburant
jusqu'à la mi-novembre une mesure
d'ailleurs proposé en france par le
parti communiste mais son précisions sur
sa durée éventuelle quelques états dont
l'italie qui subit une des hausses des
prix de l'essence les plus élevées du
continent n'ont pas encore tranché sur
la marche à suivre
la plupart se tournent donc vers
bruxelles en espérant trouver une
solution commune pour le moment la
commission européenne ne s'est pas
prononcé
et on en parle avec philippe béchade
rédacteur en chef de la bourse au
quotidien
[Musique]
philippe béchade bonjour bonjour merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation ce
matin pour parler de ce sommet européen
qui débute aujourd'hui avec au centre
des discussions la crise de l'énergie
peut-être pour commencer pourquoi cette
hausse des prix partout en europe comme
on l'expliqué aujourd'hui
sont multiples
l'éléphant dans le corridor pour
l'instant c'est le prix du gaz puisqu'il
est en hausse de 46% depuis le début de
l'année on voit également que le prix du
charbon
fortement progressé alors surtout en
chine un petit peu moins en europe mais
en europe c'est quand même un facteur
important pour des pays comme comme la
pologne
l'allemagne avec ses centrales au
charbon
du mecklenburg
hausse du pétrole dont on ne sait depuis
un an
il a doublé enfin par rapport à octobre
dernier d'ailleurs on battait hier soir
un nouveau record de 7 ans aussi bien à
londres qu'à new york et puis il ya bien
sûr les fameux crédits carbone puisque
l'europe a imposé dans le cadre des
mesures de réduction des émissions de
co2 donc
un objectif
devenir de 55% déjà les émissions d'ici
2030 pour parvenir à la neutralité
carbone d'ici
2050 et déjà ses 55 % de réduction
oblige à faire des efforts très
importants
pour réduire les émissions dès
aujourd'hui et comme il y à une reprise
post crise pandémique qui est peut-être
plus forte qu'espéré on a une demande
une demande beaucoup plus importante
alors que l'europe finalement n'a pas
anticipé est l'un des problèmes que l'on
cite c'est que nos réserves de gaz par
exemple au lieu d'être à 90 % avant les
fêtes à deux mois de la période la plus
froide on est actuellement qu'à 70%
alors on va pas manquer de gaz même à
70% de réserve mais si on voulait aller
reconstitués dès maintenant et est
remonté à la norme classique le gaz
flamberait encore beaucoup plus donc on
est obligé aujourd'hui
soit d'envisager de réduire les taxes
sur les carburants sur le gaz soyez
forts qu'on révise à la baisse nos
objectifs de neutralité carbone
peut-être les mettre entre parenthèses
quelques mois mais ça les allemands ils
n'en veulent pas et la russie s'était
d'ailleurs dit dites prêtes à intervenir
pour stabiliser les prix du gaz en
europe parce que ça voudrait dire qu'il
suffirait juste de nouveaux contrats de
livraison pour stabiliser la situation
et faire baisser les prix de l'énergie
aujourd'hui en europe
ah oui ça
l'impact mécanique et psychologique
serait serait immédiat on abord parce qu
il y a
ghizzoni qui s'appelle nord stream et
qui est maintenant opérationnel mais qui
reste pour l'instant fermé pour des
raisons politiques il suffira de dire qu
on augmente les livraisons de gaz ne
serait ce que 2 5% est et nord stream
permettra de faire beaucoup plus mais il
suffirait alors de dire quand on
augmente les approvisionnements de 5%
pour serrer immédiatement rechuter le
puits de gaz le gaz la planète n'en
manque pas ça c'est une des ressources
d'ailleurs dont on ne table pas certain
que même d'ici 2100 il n'y a aucun souci
il ya des gisements
gigantesque au qatar notamment puisque
là c'est là qu'un programme le plus
grand projet au monde
de
liquéfaction du gaz a mené par technip
énergie et un partenaire japonais
rien que ce que rien que ses capacités
supplémentaires provenant du qatar ça
devrait permettre de faire face donc là
c'est un blocage politique finalement
instant ça ressemble effectivement à un
blocage politique on sait que les
américains sont vent debout contre north
stream 2 parce que du coup et bien leur
producteur texan au dakota du nord vient
perdrait finalement a débouché pour pour
du gaz liquéfié
[Musique]
les états unis donc depuis 4 ou 5 ans
ont changé de doctrine aujourd'hui son
prêt à exporter de l'énergie et pourquoi
le gaz parce que justement de gaz
quelque part il y en a trop on a parlé
du gaz sur l'essence maintenant que peut
faire l'europe parce que les pays vont
discuter de propositions qu'ils ont
appelé la boîte à outil qu'est ce qu'il
ya comme comme proposition pour les sens
très concrètement pour les consommateurs
alors
le problème c'est que chaque pays a un
petit peu sa vision à
la france
l'espagne l'italie pencherait évidemment
pour une baisse des taxes puisque ce
sont les plus élevés d'europe on
pourrait presque dire au monde a pendant
que le litre de
gasoil aujourd'hui se traite plus très
loin maintenant de 1,60 le litre c'est
un leur auront luxembourg voilà donc il
ya quarante pays qui taxent plus c'est
la suisse voilà mais les suisses ça ça
n'affecte pas leur faim moi donc réduire
les taxes parce que c'est la part
prépondérante du prix d'un litre
les allemands eux
[Musique]
seraient pas contre mais attention les
allemands eux pensent que
le pic des prix actuelle il est
transitoire donc est ce que c est ce que
ça vaudrait la peine de modifier nos
règlements européens pour quelque chose
qui est transitoire est ce qu'on
pourrait pas tenir encore quelques
semaines et puis bang éventuellement
envisager des systèmes comme des chèques
pour aider les plus
les plus impactés les plus pénalisées
par la hausse des carburants ça c'est un
peu la piste française aussi un
cessez-le-feu et wenger thierry breton à
propos d'un filtre française pourquoi
les prix en france sont les plus sont
parmi les plus élevés
abbas et l'empilement des taxes cédant
qu'ils demandent et axa
si toutes les taxes la tpp cetera la tva
sur je sais qu'elle
[Musique]
je sais plus quelle est la partie
additionnelle que l'on doit justement à
l'europe et pour la réduction des
émissions de co2 offert à chaque fois
qu'il ya une taxe écologique et accule
halde enfin on arrive à 55 % du prix
d'un pain de du prix d'un litre qui
correspond effectivement à des taxes
voilà donc si on veut réduire le prix de
l'essence évidemment c'est pas en
supprimant les deux centimes de marge du
distributeur que ça aura un impact à
edouard leclerc michel-edouard leclerc
lui a parlé de le vendre à prix coûtant
si on vend à prix coûtant on ajuste
réduit de 2 200 le prix d'un litre donc
c'est pas c'est pas ça qui va évidemment
faire bouger les choses quand on entend
dire que il faut matraquer les
distributeurs qui s'en mettent plein les
poches
2 centimes sur un 60 fin bon c'est
ridicule c'est bien le problème le
problème vient bien ça me tient des
taxes sachant que le carburant lui-même
aujourd'hui représente même pas 50
centimes assurent les associations de
compagnies merci beaucoup philippe
béchade pour voter un éclairage ce matin
sur rtl france je le rappelle vous êtes
rédacteur en chef de la bourse au
quotidien
[Musique]
un sommet européen qui fera aussi
largement consacré au bras de fer avec
la pologne lors de son audition devant
le parlement mardi à strasbourg le
premier ministre polonais a fustigé je
cite le chantage de bruxelles exercée
sur son pays sur la question de la
primauté du droit européen pour ses
réformes judiciaires controversé la
pologne a vu son plan de relance gelée
par l'union européenne regarde et
wolof là est la règle de la loi n
oubliant qui rassemble notre union c'est
la fondation même de notre unité c'est
déterminant pour la protection des
valeurs sur lesquelles l'europe a basé
sa nou socle de notre unité cet
essentiel pour protéger les valeurs sur
lesquelles l'europe et font des nobles
démocratie liberté égalité et respect
des droits humains
et c'est ce pourquoi les 27 pays membres
ont signé en tant que participant à
cette union en tant que pays souverain
et peuples libres
nous ne pouvons pas nous ne voulons pas
laisser nos valeurs communes être mises
en danger
la commission agira et les options sont
toutes connues
il n'est pas acceptable d'imposer aux
autres ses décisions sans fondement
juridique il est d'autant pas acceptable
d'utiliser à cette fin le chantage
financier de parler de sanctions ou
d'utiliser un langage qui va encore plus
loin en l'encontre de certains pays
membres
je rejette ce langage des menaces ou de
la coercition je refuse que les
politiciens en face du chantage et
menace la pologne
[Musique]
et le pouvoir d'achat principales
préoccupations des français en ce moment
avec la hausse du prix de l'essence
baisse des taxes ou chèque carburant
l'exécutif n'a toujours pas tranché des
annonces très attendues par les
automobilistes selon un dernier sondage
voilà le sujet devance largement les
problématiques liées à l'immigration ou
à la sécurité ou le voyait avec 45 %
soit près d'un français sur deux places
le pouvoir d'achat en
priorité de ses préoccupations l
approche de la présidentielle alors
quelles seraient les mesures qui
pourraient vous aider à maintenir votre
pouvoir d'achat on vous a posé la
question regarder
je sais j'ai l'impression que le pouvoir
d'achat c'est un curseur qui entre les
mains de quelqu'un qui peut le monter
descendre mais je pense c'est beaucoup
plus complexe que ça il ya une semaine
j'ai entendu parler d'un responsable
politique futur candidat qui disaient
non on va on va enlever la taxe
audiovisuelle c'est va augmenter le
pouvoir d'achat je pense pas que 130
euros va modifier le quotidien des
français la petite ménagère qui gagnent
pas beaucoup elle n'a pas la même vision
du pouvoir d'achat que celui qui veut
qui peut pas aller au restaurant trois
fois par semaine dont il ira uniquement
deux fois donc c'est très 6 à géométrie
variable a augmenté leurs tracts puisque
moi je suis à la retraite ça fait deux
ans ou trois ans que n'y a pas eu
d'augmentation des retraites donc ce
serait bien d'augmenter notre pouvoir
d'achat d'autant plus qu'on a été très
pénalisée avec la csg fait partie de la
taille et la catégorie des bons
retraités on va dire et en paye toujours
la taxe d'habitation par exemple on sait
pas quand est-ce que ça va partir je ne
sais pas si c'est par rapport au fait
que les logements est le plus coûteux à
paris mais en tout cas de ma situation
j'ai vécu dans un appartement qui était
assez dégradés j'ai dû enfin ma famille
a dû payer 1000 euros par mois alors que
ça nous rendait malade
bajeux pas maîtriser encore plus les
loyers sur paris en tout cas ça c'est
vraiment spécifique à la ville de paris
je sais que nous c'est une grosse part
de notre budget donc donc voilà les
et je pense que c'est vraiment le
le point sensible dans les budgets des
parisiens en tout cas déjà le chèque
carburant si le maître c'est déjà pas
mal et d'autres moyens honnêtement je ne
sais pas mais moi je suis travailleur
indépendant
et je suis dans le transport je suis
très impactées par le l'augmentation du
gazoil je pense que le gouvernement
pourrait déjà limiter l'inflation si ça
peut être possible chaque carburant je
pense pas que ce soit une solution parce
que soit on diminue les taxes soit
faut trouver une autre solution à ce que
maintenant il faut plus fort était un
peu de donner moi dans mon cas par
exemple revoir l'aide au logement ce
serait un bon
belles choses pour le pouvoir d'achat
une crise énergétique qui a relancé en
tout cas la mobilisation des gilet jaune
samedi dernier et d'autres
manifestations sont déjà prévues ce week
end alors le gouvernement va-t-il devoir
affronter une nouvelle crise sociale de
grande ampleur à six mois de l'élection
présidentielle
on voit cela avec notre sociologue
michel fize
[Musique]
michel fize bonjour
bonjour heureux de vous retrouver ce
matin dans la matinale alors selon le
dernier sondage et lab 57% des français
ont le sentiment que leur pouvoir
d'achat a baissé depuis le début du
quinquennat d'emmanuel macron la réalité
n'est-elle pas plus préoccupante
je crois que ce sondage n'est qu'un pâle
reflet d'une réalité qui est devenu
beaucoup plus inquiétante car un certain
nombre de catégories sont sont pointés 1
par ce sondage
bon les catégories je dirais habituel
les ouvriers les ruraux qui sont pour
partie des gilets jaunes des employés
est alors fait nouveau fait son entrée
la couche moyenne à les professions
intermédiaires se montre aujourd'hui
parmi les préoccupent et alors ce que le
sondage ne ne dit pas c'est que en
réalité à côté des 10 ou 12 millions de
pauvres et on peut penser que le chiffre
est beaucoup supérieur il y à toutes ces
personnes vulnérables que le credoc a
estimé à environ 4 millions alors qui
comprend tous ceux qui n'ont pas été
cités me semble-t-il dans ce sondage et
les jeunes les jeunes étudiants les
jeunes actifs du secteur privé surtout
quand ils sont en contrat précaire est
chargé de famille de surcroît les femmes
surtout quand elles sont issus de
familles monoparentales les chômeurs
quand ils sont en fin de droits ou
qu'ils ont peu de droits à faire valoir
et puis n'oublions pas les retraités
ceux qui ont des carrières hachées mais
également ceux qui sont dans des
secteurs particulièrement préoccupant je
pense notamment aux agriculteurs et aux
travailleurs aux travailleurs
indépendants donc on a on a une francine
y seraient en réalité si on voulait
résumer il y a aujourd'hui de france il
y à une france riche et aisée qui
d'ailleurs ne doit pas comprendre ce
dont nous parlons ce matin et puis la
france la plus nombreuse c'est une
france pauvre qui s'est appauvrie une
france vulnérables précaires qui risque
à tout instant de tomber dans la dans la
réalité il faut bien avoir conscience
que derrière ces chiffres il y à des
êtres humains il ya des hommes des
femmes des enfants 1 qui souffrent au
quotidien
on sait depuis longtemps qu'il y a
effectivement des personnes qui vivent
dans leur voiture un qui vivent dans des
caves dans des parkings voilà c'est ça
la réalité aujourd'hui la pauvreté donc
pour vous c'est en bien plus au delà en
tout cas de ce que de scanner que ce
sondage
oui bien sûr je crois qu'on a un
appauvrissement réel alors évidemment ce
qui est assez préoccupant en démocratie
c'est qu'on a parallèlement un
enrichissement qui est aussi bien réelle
c'est on a beaucoup parlé de l'epargne
qui a été amassée par les français
durant durant la crise mais ce que l'on
n'a pas dit c'est que 70% de cette
épargne a été réalisée par 20% des
ménages aisés 1 selon le donc l'enquète
l' enquête du credoc donc on assiste à 7
à cette situation que les plus riches
durant la crise se sont enrichis encore
un l'image des patrons des grands
groupes qui soit américain ou français
un bon amazon facebook
microsoft et puis bernard arnault pour
l'industrie du luxe en france la fortune
des dix premiers milliardaires a été
multiplié par deux en un an donc ça
accrédite cette thèse de deux francs ce
qui semble aujourd'hui complètement tiré
conciliables complètement éloignées
l'une de l'autre et du coup michel la
situation actuelle marquée par
d'importantes hausses de prix de
produits tant énergétique alimentaire
est ce que cela ne risque pas au fond de
conduire un nouveau grand mouvement
social comme celui des gilets jaunes en
vous savez on n'a pas besoin d'être un
expert pour dire que 2021 c'est 2018 en
pire 1 je rappelle que la hausse des
carburants a été l'élément détonateur du
mouvement des gilets jaunes en novembre
2018 aujourd'hui beaucoup plus encore de
gilet jaune sont préoccupés par cette
hausse vertigineuse alors on annonce
évidemment des mesures
immédiates ou qui vont l'être comme un
chèque carburant mais on parle aussi
d'un chèque de 50 à 60 euros mais 50 à
60 euros pour passer tout l'automne et
tout l'hiver ou 50 à 60 euros
mensuels payés tout ça ce sont des
rustines c'est pas ainsi qu'on va
effectivement enrayer cette formidable
hausse du pouvoir d'achat qui touche
encore à la fois les actifs les
retraités les jeunes les seniors les
personnes en ehpad ou qui ne sont pas en
ehpad les hommes les femmes et tout le
monde est aujourd'hui concerné c'est ce
que l'on pourrait appeler la
nationalisation de la pauvreté de la
précarité
merci beaucoup michel pour votre analyse
et on attend évidemment là les mesures
du gouvernement qui ne serait tarder
concernant la led pour les
automobilistes justement sur le prix de
l'essence et la piste en tout cas d'un
d'un chèque est censée la piste
privilégiée pour l'instant bruno le
maire l'a confirmé hier en tout cas la
piste des taxes est exclu pour l'instant
merci michel fize
est tout de suite donc c'est là est la
revue de presse de la rédaction de rtl
france avec olivier de 40 flec
[Musique]
et olivier on commence avec jeune
afrique qui revient sur les statistiques
du colis de l'om est sur le continent
africain oui effectivement puisque
presque 1 8 million et demi d'africains
ont eu le qu'ovide 240 de 114 mille ans
sont morts mais pour la directrice
régionale de l'om est ce le docteur
moati il faut multiplier ce chiffre est
bien par 7 soit 59 millions de malades
et un million et demi de morts pour
endiguer la maladie le ms prône la
stratégie de la même stratégie que celle
contre ebola il s'agit de tester sur la
base du volontariat toutes les personnes
vivant dans un rayon de 100 mètres
autour du cas découverts peut-on lire
dans l'article et distribuer les jets
les masques à tous les ménages dans ce
périmètre un budget de 1 million 8 de
dollars a été dégagée par l' oms pour
aider les huit pays pilotes à financer
ces mesures les directions des deux
brésil à présent avec cet article de
brazil des fatto une une
révélations exclusives sur la décision
de ras-le-bol sauna ou d'envoyer 41
militaires brésiliens en formation aux
états unis oui c'est une décision qui
fait parler puisque ces militaires sont
envoyés au wynn c'est qu'un centre à la
réputation controversée un centre
militaire connue pour avoir formé des
soldats anti communiste devenu ensuite
putschistes ou membres de gendarmes et
sept soldats colombiens d'ailleurs ils
sont passés et ont été impliqués dans le
meurtre du président haïtien jo venelles
moïse connu pour sa proximité avec
donald trump jr ball sonar ou inquiètes
et observateurs avisés brésilien dans
cette course pour la présidentielle la
politologue luciana via chi-x qui estime
qu pardon c'est compliqué à prononcer
estime que l'augmentation du nombre de
soldats envoyés à office et qu'en 2021
peut-être justifiée par la volonté de
guérir ball sonar ou d'un coup d'état au
brésil un discours répété à quelques
reprises au cours de la vie oui c'est
bien le polonais la matinale vivait au
japon peut-être plus simple le quotidien
a failli nous apprend qu'un traitement
contre le co lead est en passe d'être
validé oui et le non de ce médicament
américain je vais essayer
c'est le maul nu pire à vire alors en
tout cas c'est une ville qui réduira les
risques d'hospitalisation et de décès de
50% à la peine avec une sixième vague le
japon lui cherche une alternative à la
vaccination en prévision d'un afflux de
touristes dans un accord gagnant gagnant
avec le laboratoire américain merck ce
qu'ils prévoient de demander
prochainement à la food and drug
administration des états unis une
autorisation du liquide utilisé
d'urgence le médicament la société
demandera également au ministère
japonais de la santé d'approuver la
fabrication et la vente de ce médicament
au japon une option de plus donc dans le
pays qui a fait de la fait la part belle
aux traitements antiviraux selon les
chiffres avancés par le gouvernement
américain le prix de chaque dose deux
menus pas vire avoisinerait les 700
dollars
[Musique]
allez de quitter cette matinale cette
image pour finir vous le voyez des
dizaines de femmes et d'athlètes afghans
ont quitté kaboul pour le qatar hier
dans le cadre d'une série d'évacuation
organisée par le gouvernement qatari en
coopération avec la fifa et parmi les
évacués notamment la star du sport
féminin à la basketteuse tyra et liu
sophie des rates une ville à l'ouest de
l'afghanistan elle est attendue au
canada à présent au total 3 169
passagers ont été évacuées d'afghanistan
et c'est la fin de cette marche si
naturelle et france merci de votre
fidélité
on a beaucoup de mal à prononcer les
mots sont maintenant un peu fatigué
c'est la fin de semaine merci beaucoup
en tout cas on se retrouve lundi même
heure même tasse et je vous serais ce
magali puisque je vais me reposer un
petit peu on a pu constater j'en ai
besoin je vous retrouve une bonne
journée
[Musique]
le résultat d'un dieu peut réserver bien
des surprises pour mieux comprendre vous
aideront à y voir clair
[Musique]
il ya eu celle et panama peppers les
paradise peppers place aujourd'hui aux
pandora peppers la plupart de ces de ces
opérations sont en fait